My working Assumption is we'll have a general election
in the second half of this year.
And in the meantime
I've got lots that I wanna get on with
whenever the general election will be.
Though one thing really is for sure,
the mainstream meter is pretty breath of left wing
perspective.
Uh, and we want to scale up our resources
so that we can provide the widespread coverage
the left really deserves
to ramp up our scrutiny of policy,
stand up for people's humanity,
rights and living standards
and really hold a politicians account
across the political spectrum.
So if you're able to support independent,
truthful media in 2024,
head to Navarro media.comslashsupport
to join our regular supports from just £1 per month.
Because this is the election year
to end all election years
and we wanna be across it globally,
not just in the UK.